Book to Movie adaptations are tricky to the
point where the phrase “the book was better”
has become a cliche.
The book, The Disaster Artist, is one of my
favorite books about filmmaking.
It’s about Tommy Wiseau, the infamous creator
of The Room and is written by Tommy’s best
friend and co-star Greg Sestero.
The book is not only the behind the scenes
tale of the making of what has been dubbed
“the greatest bad movie of all time”,
it’s the story of the strange, eccentric,
mysterious man behind the film.
So naturally I was interested when I found
out that James Franco was directing an adaptation
of Greg’s Book.
And the first question I had about the film,
was what will Tommy think of the movie?
We eventually got the answer, which surprised
me, since famous Tommy only approved of Greg’s
book 40%.
So why does Tommy love the movie and dislike
the book?
Is it just another strange Tommy Wiseau quirk?
I don’t think so, and in fact I think the
disparity lies at the heart of why Franco’s
movie is not a good adaptation.
When it comes to adaptations fans often get
upset about small changes or “inaccuracies”.
In a strange way, The Disaster Artist is obsessed
with accuracy on a detail level.
Many scenes are fairly close to what’s in
the book.
And as the movie proudly shows us at the end,
much care was taken to accurately re-create
actual scenes from The Room.
Franco’s performance as Tommy is also surprisingly
good.
It’s about as accurate an embodiment of
Tommy as we could ask for.
And yet to me something is still felt… off.
The Disaster Artist is accurate on a micro
scale.
But I think the changes is does make shift
the heart of the story in a way that is interesting,
but ultimately detrimental to the story.
The Tommy Greg illustrates for us in the book
is difficult to understand and deal with.
He’s complicated and fascinating.
He’s a stubborn hopeful who is mysteriously
wealthy.
Greg’s depiction of Tommy is certainly caring
and sympathetic, but it’s also laced with
honesty about the darker side of the story,
it’s not afraid to criticize it’s subject.
Franco’s Tommy retains some of these qualities,
but ultimately distills Tommy down into a
sort of underdog hero.
Franco’s Tommy is a quirky guy who sticks
to his dream and wins against all odds.
And Franco’s movie celebrates that.
Sure it highlights some of the frustrating
Tommy moments and
the crew’s exasperation, but it does so
mostly for comedic effect.
While in the film tension between Greg and
Tommy is a plot point late in the second act.
In the book, this tension is at the core of
what makes the story so interesting.
The movie displays Greg’s participation
and cheerleader attitude without revealing
the internal struggle and self-awareness that
accompanied that.
In the movie Greg is simplified to someone
who worships Tommy’s self-confidence,
and only really second-guesses things when
Tommy gets in the way of his career.
In the book Greg refuses to be in The Room
at first, only eventually giving in.
Missing from the film is a close examination
of Greg.
Why does Greg, knowing things are bad, continue
to enable and support Tommy?
Is he just being a good friend?
Is blindly encouraging someone when you know
what they’re making isn’t good being a
good friend?
Greg even questions himself throughout
the book.
The movie overlooks some of the darker themes
and trauma that may have led to Tommy’s
creation of the room.
In the book Tommy disappears for a while,
Greg, unable to get in contact with him, is
quite worried something bad may have happened.
Tommy eventually re-appears and decides to
film The Room.
Gone from this movie is Tommy’s dark night
of the soul, it’s reduced to a sort of feel-good
pep-talk.
And in one of the most tonally dissonant moments
I’ve seen a film in a while Franco’s movie
presents a theater full of people chanting
for a character to kill themselves, and expects
us to accept it as a positive thing.
Look at how Greg describes the story he tells
in the book, compared with how Franco describes
the story he’s telling in the movie.
Greg’s book is a tragedy.
It doesn’t give us a happy ending.
We the audience, with hindsight, know Tommy
will eventually become accepted and loved,
though not in the way Tommy wanted.
The movie is a comedy, it treats it’s story
as the classic “if you dream big and work
hard you’ll succeed” story but with a
twist.
It’s celebrates Tommy’s success, and shows
Tommy accepting the backwards nature of his
success without much struggle.
While the Movie might be accurate about a
lot of things, the heart of the story is completely
different.
It’s a poor adaptation in the macro sense.
This oversimplification of Tommy into a hero
character I think is obviously at the heart
of Tommy’s love of the film.
Tommy loves the movie because it presents
him in the best possible light.
But by doing so the story is stripped of it’s
humanity.
And I get it, it’s nice to imagine Tommy
this way.
It’s nice to imagine that we live in a world
where if you’re bad at what you do you’ll
still end up successful, famous, and happy.
That’s the fun story to tell.
And maybe in this case it’s the true one.
There’s another piece to this puzzle, The
Disaster Artist, book and movie, are both
“Adaptations” of real life.
So while the movie is partly an adaptation
of the book, it’s also and adaptation of
Franco and the writer’s perspective on the
real life story.
Greg’s book isn’t the definitive truth
and it’s possible that it is colored unnecessarily
dark by his personal involvement and subjective
experience.
This is a revealing example of how difficult
good adaptation really is.
I don’t think Franco’s movie is a dishonest
adaptation.
It doesn’t lie about Tommy and the story.
But by choosing what to include and leave
out, and changing the tone of the presentation
you can create a very different story.
But personally I find the book to be much
more interesting and thought provoking.
The movie wants us to believe there’s something
about Tommy that makes The Room, not just
a terrible movie, but a special movie.
And I agree.
But it only explores Tommy on a surface level.
And in a strange way I feel like the movie
is the sort of plastic, fake, story that Tommy
is so quick to criticize.
I originally listened to Greg’s book as
an audiobook on a road trip, and the trip
when by in a flash.
That’s why Audible is the perfect sponsor
for todays video.
The Disaster Artist is one of those Audiobooks
where I can definitely say that listening
to it as an audiobooks is a better experience
than reading the book.
Greg Sestero narrates the audiobook himself,
and he does a fantastic impression of Tommy’s
voice, (It’s at least as good as Franco’s,
maybe better.)
It’s a hilarious, poignant, book that I
highly recommend and you can get it for free
when you sign up for a free 30 day trial using
the link the the description.
I would never be able to read as much as I
do if it weren’t for audiobooks and Audible
is the best way to get audiobooks.
I listen to audiobooks while I’m cooking,
falling asleep, driving, editing videos, and
basically during any activity that doesn’t
require me to using my ears.
“Audible is offering you guys a free audiobook
with a 30-day trial membership.
Just go to www.audible.com/thomasflight or
text thomasflight to 500-500 and you get a
free book.
Also they have a Great Listen Guarantee, if
you don’t like a book, you can just swap
it out for another.
So go to audible dot com slash thomasflight
or text thomasflight to 500-500.
Let me know what else I should be listening
too in the comments below!